merci
Eric Carouge de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure sénateur
socialiste des Landes vice-présidents de
la délégation sénatoriale au
collectivité territoriale et elle a
décentralisation on va parler d'abord du
Congrès des mères puisque on l'a vu
Emmanuel Macron sera dans les allées du
Salon des mers cet après-midi pas de
discours devant les élus c'est un
mauvais signal pour vous
c'est très surprenant et c'est toujours
étonnant de voir comment Emmanuel Macron
ne sait pas faire avec les élus locaux
il est toujours à contretemps à
contre-pied et là dans une période où
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il y a
une incompréhension il y a une
inquiétude des élus locaux on a le
président de la République qui est à
côté d'eux mais pas vraiment avec eux et
je trouve que le signal parce qu'il y a
enfin les locaux et les maires
singulièrement attendent des réponses
n'attendent pas d'avoir le président à
côté ils attendent d'avoir le président
avec ce choix est très et très
surprenant mais encore une fois il est
toujours à contretemps avec les élus
locaux
quinquennat les élus nous disent que ça
se passe mieux avec Elizabeth borne que
ça ne se passait dans le précédent
quinquennat c'est pas votre avis alors
sans doute que ça se passe moins mal
mais enfin
un petit peu compliqué par rapport non
mais ce que je veux dire par c'est que
il n'y a pas de il y a pas d'habitude du
président de l'actuel président de la
République avec avec les avec les élus
locaux il y a une incompréhension des
territoires et puis quand on a besoin
des maires pendant la crise des gilets
jaunes on les remet en valeur et puis là
il y a des signaux il y a des signaux
contradictoires je dis pas qu'il y a pas
de je dis pas que qui a pas qu'il y a
pas de dialogue mais il y a une vraie
difficulté avec le président de la
République singulièrement Emmanuel
Macron et l'Élysée qui vendent le retour
de l'État dans les territoires ce serait
aussi l'un des thèmes de sa visite cet
après-midi il annoncé notamment en
octobre la réouverture de six
sous-préfecture c'était l'une de vos
recommandations vous êtes satisfait
alors en fait
nous avons constaté dans le rapport
rendu avec Agnès canaillé pour la
délégation en collectivité territoriale
je vais vous donner deux chiffres dans
les directions départementales
interministérielle donc l'état local
hors-préfecture il y avait 40 000 agents
en 2012 il y en a plus que 25000 voilà
donc on a eu une chute de 15000 agents
c'est catastrophique parce que la
substance de l'État local a disparu on
est à l'os parce qu'il y a plus de
muscles et donc c'est pas en rajoutant
quelques sous-préfectures que ça va
suffire l'ampleur de l'effort qui serait
à faire et tellement important que
j'allais dire même si c'est
remarquable ou intéressant pour les
territoires concernés c'est incomparable
par rapport à l'effort qu'il faudrait
faire localement juste un autre chiffre
dans l'enquête que nous avons fait
auprès des élus locaux dans ce rapport
75% d'entre eux nous disent que le
service public local de l'État s'est
dégradé dans leur territoire trois
quarts d'entre eux il y a une
préoccupation des mères c'est la
question de la sécurité vous qui êtes
aussi à l'enquête annuelle du CV qui est
sorti et qui montre 63% des maires se
disent victimes d'incivilité ce qu'ils
sont suffisamment encadrés suffisamment
protégés ces élus locaux
il y a un durcissement
des rapports sociaux parce que on est
dans une situation sociale
âpre et
les élus n'échappent plus à ces tensions
comme ça pu être le cas on va dire il y
a 20 il y a 20 30 ans ils sont pris au
sein des contradictions locales ils sont
pris à partie et exercer la fonction des
Luc local exercer singulièrement la
fonction de maire c'est de plus en plus
compliqué parce que on se met en
porte-à-faux vis-à-vis de citoyens qui
n'ont plus le même ou non pas le même
respect de la du mandat qu'il du mandat
qu'ils occupent ça veut dire qu'on va
vers une crise d'évocation et une mise
en danger de la démocratie alors
tout ça étant ambivalent parce que si
les élus constatent la montée des
incivilités pour autant et vous l'avez
vu à la fin de l'enquête ils mettent en
valeur le sens justement de leur
fonction le sens de leur engagement
auprès de leur territoire et pour
transformer leur territoire auprès des
auprès des citoyens donc il y a quand
même cette conscience que il joue et
c'est le cas un rôle important
localement mais que cette tension
derrière elle ajoute elle ajoute à
stress dans l'exercice dans l'exercice
au quotidien et nous continuons on va
faire des propositions pour encadrer au
mieux justement les débordements
vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis de ses élus
est-ce que la loi est suffisante est-ce
que c'est un problème d'application des
décisions de justice où il faut
renforcer la loi
alors je crois les deux je pense qu'il
faut
encore durcir pour dire tout simplement
que aux gens qui seraient tentés de
faire que c'est pas anodin de s'attaquer
à quelqu'un qui représente la
collectivité au moment où elle ou il
était élu donc ça c'est la première
chose mais bien entendu il faut que les
mesures soient suivies des faits parce
que il faut pas que ça soit dans l'ordre
on soit dans l'ordre du du symbole et la
ligne de crête elle est un petit peu
difficile à tenir il y a un autre sujet
de préoccupation évidemment c'est la
question des finances on va parler du
budget dans quelques instants le thème
de ce congrès des mères c'est le pouvoir
agir des mères sont inquiets pour leur
match de manœuvre ils sont impuissants
aujourd'hui face à la Hauser ils sont
impuissants ils la subissent la question
du
la question du du prix de l'énergie la
question du chauffage la question
du maintien des des services publics à
un moment où tout augmente oui c'est
c'est une question du quotidien pour
chacun des mères surtout que l'argent
que l'on consacre les sommes que l'on
consacre à ces dépenses inattendues
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas attendu il
y a 6 ou 7 mois et bien on ne peut pas
le consacrer j'allais dire au reste au
plus important dans l'enquête du cevipov
les maires nous disent à 43% ben si j'ai
ces dépenses alors je ferai la
transition écologique moins vite parce
que je n'ai plus les moyens de mettre
les choses de mettre les choses en place
donc les élus ont l'impression les mers
ont l'impression les présidents de PCI
ont l'impression d'être mis dans un dans
un étau et
par ailleurs on ne leur donne pas de
de réponse on en revient à ce qu'on se
disait au début puisque vous parlez de
la transition énergétique mais pas que
c'est aussi moins d'investissement c'est
aussi moins de services publics avec des
conséquences pour les Français c'est
exactement le risque quand c'est
typiquement la mise en place d'un cercle
vicieux comment je maintiens le même
niveau de service public alors même que
je sais que c'est une nécessité pour
certains des citoyens sinon pour tous
comment je tiens cette comment je tiens
cette équation et et j'entends je
discute avec bien entendu avec beaucoup
de beaucoup de mer il y a vraiment une
double inquiétude en ce moment c'est
d'abord et avant tout le prix de le prix
de l'énergie et donc les moyens et puis
d'une certaine façon le zéro
artificialisation nette qui est un autre
sujet mais qui laisse éperçu comme un
message de de risque de développement de
risque du développement du monde rural
ou de l'absence de développement dans le
monde rural sur finir pour finir sur la
question des finances puisque vous
examinez en ce moment le budget les élus
comptent beaucoup sur le Sénat qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez faire sur ce budget
est-ce que le gouvernement est à faire
des gestes lui aussi il en a pas fait il
en a pas fait beaucoup
la question de l'encadrement des
dépenses ça c'est une vraie ligne rouge
pour les élus
possible pour vous
et pas encore discuté mais le
voilà on est encore dans les signaux
contradictoires à apporter par le
gouvernement on est avec vous on est
autour de vous et puis quand même
avec le texte qui a été voté par 49-3 à
l'Assemblée nationale on laisse cette
cette semblant cette ersatz des contrats
de des contrats de Cahors où on vous dit
quand même que par rapport aux dépenses
réelles de fonctionnement pour les plus
grands collectivités si vous si vous
mettez pas le frein et ben vous on vous
tapera on vous tapera sur les doigts
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
compréhensible et c'est difficilement
surtout entendable où on veut que les
territoires portent des politiques
publiques de développement où on veut
pas mais qu'on nous le dise on va
continuer justement à parler de ce
budget puisque le Sénat poursuit
l'examen on voit les temps forts de ces
dernières heures avec Steve Jordan
[Musique]
sur le problème des tensions sur le
marché du logement dans les zones
touristiques un problème qui touche
notamment la Bretagne les Alpes le Pays
Basque ou encore la Corse la belle Corse
Orient bref toutes ces zones dans
lesquelles les touristes aiment aller
dans lesquelles ceux qui le peuvent
achètent des résidences secondaires ils
le font au détriment parfois des
populations locales qui ont contrepartie
voit les prix du logement explosé dans
la ville plusieurs manifestations ont
d'ailleurs eu lieu un 7 automne pour
demander aux élus de mieux réguler le
marché du logement dans ces zones
touristiques le sujet s'inviter dans
l'hémicycléaire
comme une rurales qui sont aujourd'hui
confrontés à l'exode d'habitants des
métropoles et en conséquence l'envoler
des coûts du logement premier poste de
dépenses des ménages rend difficile pour
les conseils municipaux l'ajustement
fiscale de ce phénomène récent de ce
phénomène d'ampleur quels sont les
dispositifs prévus aujourd'hui alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à partir de
l'année prochaine la taxe d'habitation
s'est terminée pour tous les français
sauf sur les résidences secondaires
c'est un détail qu'on oublie un peu la
taxe d'habitation ne disparaît pas
complètement et les mères peuvent déjà
aujourd'hui surtaxer les résidences
secondaires au titre de la taxe
d'habitation il s'agit des maires élus
dans des agglomérations de plus de 50
000 habitants classés zone tendue on
parle aujourd'hui de un peu plus de 1000
communes au total Oriane on a bien
compris le dispositif le gouvernement
voulait étendre ce dispositif le Sénat
dit oui mais pas trop au gouvernement
propose d'élargir les zones ou les mers
ont la possibilité de majorer la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires 4000 nouvelles collectivités
pourraient désormais avoir la
possibilité
augmenter cette taxe là encore il s'agit
de zones où le marché immobilier est
tendu hier le Sénat a voté pour un
encadrement de la surtax elle ne pourra
pas aller au-delà de 25% écoutez on
craint aussi ce qui pourrait apparaître
comme une sorte de matraqua des
résidences secondaires il y a plus de 3
millions de résidences secondaires en
France pour les deux tiers elles
appartiennent à des personnes de plus de
60 ans qui n'ont pas tous des retraites
élevées et donc il faut à mon avis
mettre une limite tout de même
ericaus l'objectif de ce dispositif
c'est quoi c'est d'instaurer un rapport
de force avec certains propriétaires et
peut-être aussi les plateformes Airbnb
c'est absolument c'est absolument
nécessaire alors vous avez parlé du
Pays Basque mais juste au dessus du Pays
Basque il y a les Landes qui sont très
fréquentées aussi
au niveau au niveau touristique j'habite
dans le sud de ce département et on est
en train de connaître des évolutions
accélérées qui au sens littéral rendent
la vie impossible localement
les dans la commune dans laquelle
j'habite et j'ai longtemps été élu
Capbreton on a des prix maintenant qui
frôle les et qui peuvent dépasser même
les 10000 euros le mètre carré pour pour
des appartements c'est sans sans lien
avec les moyens réels qui existent sur
le territoire et donc vous avez d'une
certaine façon un peu partout sur les
littoraux français chez moi comme dans
le Pays Basque mais même dans des
départements ruraux comme comme
l'Ardèche vous avez une poussée
tellement forte que les populations
locales ne peuvent plus acquérir chez
elle elles sont vraiment poussées de
plus en plus loin à l'intérieur du des
territoires ça crée une frustration très
très forte les moyens enfonciers des
communes sont très limités je sais que
sur ma commune nous avons fait des
efforts importants en termes de
logements sociaux mais encore faut-il
avoir du foncier à un moment donné on en
a plus et on crée de la frustration
locale et surtout vous avez une montée
des prix qui fait que les gens dont on a
besoin pour travailler sur place et bien
sont de plus en plus loin de l'endroit
où il travaille qui était avant chez eux
donc là il y a vraiment une bombe à
retardement
territoriale les les revenus de Airbnb
sur les Landes ont augmenté de 125% par
rapport à 2019 c'est à peu près un
revenu de 15 millions pour l'Ardèche
c'est 100% c'est un revenu de de 18
millions donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
économie aussi de rente et
la difficulté c'est que c'est pas le a
priori contre les résidences secondaires
sauf que quand on a une résidence
secondaire ça veut dire quand même qu'on
a une résidence principale donc on n'est
pas dans latitude la même situation que
la plupart des des Français mais au-delà
de ça c'est pas c'est pas la résidence
secondaire c'est ce qui est fait de
cette résidence secondaire si elle est
pensée pour du locatif notamment pendant
la saison ou par le biais des
plateformes et bien entendu ça génère
une spirale inflationniste qui n'est pas
tenable et qui se diffuse sur toute la
France littoral et on génère vraiment
des frustrations dont je pense pas que
le gouvernement mesure l'importance
actuellement
Steve le Sénat c'est penché sur un autre
sujet sensible en ce moment toujours sur
l'action du logement oui le Sénat cette
fois-ci en accord avec le gouvernement
pas question de revaloriser les appels
les allocations logement avaient déjà
été revalorisé cet été de 3,5% par
l'exécutif mais la gauche sénatoriale
considère qu'avec l'inflation cette
hausse est désormais insuffisante elle a
demandé un nouveau coup de pouce écoutez
donc ce qui est demandé par sa maman
franchement
c'est c'est sérieux quoi c'est
responsable vous voyez c'est une
revalorisation de 15 euros et croyez moi
ici je crois qu'on connaît tous ici les
modalités de calcul pour toucher l'APL
il faut quand même pas avoir grand chose
voyez 2 33 nous on dit 15 euros voilà
c'est c'est un signe quoi un signe que
n'a pas voulu envoyer le gouvernement
qui considère notamment que l'exécutif
fait déjà beaucoup Gabriel Attal a
évoqué la prime de rentrer encore le
chèque énergie qui devrait tomber dans
les semaines qui viennent c'est pas
suffisant
non mais c'est le dérisoire de la
réponse de du ministre qui est étonnante
on augmente pas les appels parce qu'on a
fait le chèque enfin c'est pas c'est pas
sérieux c'est juste pas sérieux le
problème c'est que les salaires sont bas
en France et qu'il faut absolument les
augmenter c'est pas pour rien qu'on
demande une augmentation du SMIC ou
alors on veut répondre aux difficultés
sociales où on veut pas y répondre et on
y répond pas par des chèques ou par ou
par des allocations et puis sur le point
spécifique du logement
ça fait le lien avec le sujet qu'on
vient d'aborder il y a une autre
difficulté c'est que en termes de
logements sociaux la politique et le
bilan
du précédent quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron comme de celui qui s'annonce sera
catastrophique du point de vue du
logement social parce qu'à force de
prélever sur le logement social à force
de mettre en situation difficile
l'ensemble des organismes de logement
sociaux ont précipite une crise qui est
déjà très importante en France donc
voilà c'est pas les allocations c'est
pas le chèque énergie qui va compenser
le fait qu'il y aurait besoin de plus
d'APL d'une part et de logements sociaux
d'autre part la question aussi des
dépenses je sais pas si j'ai encore le
temps une minute 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sont budgété pour
l'année prochaine il y a aussi cette
question qui va payer si on débloque
encore plus d'argent pour des appels ou
pour d'autres aides qui va payer
peut-être qu'il faut arrêter de se
priver d'impôts déjà avec la avec la
baisse de la de la CVAE avec la
disparition programmée de la CVAE les
rentrées de l'État vont encore baisser
de 2,7% en volume donc on peut continuer
comme ça on peut se priver à chaque fois
de ressources et dire mais ah bah oui
mais on peut plus financer mais
forcément si on la prise de ressources
on peut plus financer soit on fait des
choix d'orthodoxie
libéraux ce que fait le gouvernement
soit on prend d'autres décisions qui
permettent de mettre de l'argent là où
les Français ont besoin qu'il soit
injecté merci à tout à l'heure on va
parler d'une autre hausse de prix oui
j'ai oublié
le Congrès des mères évidemment aussi
d'Olivier Giroud mais c'est un autre ça
sera avec les roches
du côté de Bordeaux on retrouve Xavier
sauta journaliste à sud-ouest bonjour
Xavier merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
et Xavier à la veille de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi qui vise à interdire
la corrida ce sera demain à l'Assemblée
nationale le sujet bien sûr déjà au cœur
de l'actualité chez vous
c'est animé tout le week-end on a vu des
manifestations contre manifestations un
petit peu partout dans le Sud-Ouest
chacun brandissait des enquêtes
d'opinion des chiffres des chiffres
saisonniers ces innocents qui va vous
facilement sous la torture donc on voit
qu'il y a une vraie levée de bouclier
pourquoi bah c'est assez simple le
Sud-Ouest et une terre de corrida une
terre d'afficionne comme on dit ici et
on voit ben dans la répartition dans la
lecture politique une répartition des
rôles on va dire un grosso modo pour
résumer je la prendrai pas à Eric et
mouche mais les élus du Sud-Ouest font
bloc pour s'opposer à l'interdiction de
la corrida néanmoins on voit apparaître
quelques lignes de fracture notamment au
sein de la nupesse puisque aux élus
socialistes ont globalement favorables à
cette pratique à cet art euro-macique
tel qu'il est présenté et pour trouver
les opposants ben il faut aller en
secteur urbain on va dire autour de
Bordeaux notamment on a deux députés qui
sont très actifs sur le sujet l'écologie
Nicolas Thierry élu de Bordeaux député
de Bordeaux ou l'insomnie Loïc
Prud'homme et lui de circonscriptions
urbaines
vous faites un petit retour en arrière
puisque dans les années 80 déjà
l'interdiction de la corrida susciter de
fortes oppositions
et si vous voulez c'est une histoire
vous savez nos journaux de la mémoire
c'est eux c'est leur grand intérêt et en
fait on s'est penché sur le cas de
Florac pourquoi Floirac parce que et
bien cette ville de la de la rive droite
en 1987 décide d'organiser une corrida
pour renouer avec une tradition
tauromachique je vais pas vous faire
l'histoire à la tauromation Gironde
néanmoins elle est assez longue et en
fait c'est un vrai moment fondateur à la
fois pour les antitorins comme pour les
procorina pourquoi pour les antitorins
en fait il y a des résonances très
curieuses avec l'actualité 87 cette
ville décide d'organiser cette corrida
et on assiste à des scènes assez folles
qui font parter qui font penser au
bassines notamment hein ces
manifestations que vous avez vu
puisqu'on a des activités technologiques
qui envahissent la mairie de Bordeaux
qui viennent recouvrir de peinture une
tapisserie des Gobelins qui Ornella ça
des mariages on a une église qui est
taguée et on a même été jusqu'à un
incendie du parking municipal de Floirac
4 bus scolaires qui ont été ben voilà
dévasté par les flammes et à l'époque on
parlait de terroristes pas des côtes
terroristes et de terroriste et de
l'autre côté pour les proto-100 moments
assez fondateur pourquoi parce que cette
question la tradition locale
ininterrompue la jurisprudence a été
prise ici à Bordeaux autour de la tenue
de cette corrida alors elle a été
contestée jusqu'au début des années 2000
mais c'est aujourd'hui que se fonde la
possibilité de faire des corridas dans
des terres à tradition et une
interrompue et pour l'anecdote en fait
c'est un jeune avocat qui l'a obtenu à
l'époque cette jurisprudence c'est un
Anziani qui a été longtemps questeur au
Palais du Luxembourg est aujourd'hui
président de Bordeaux métropole
c'est ce sujet va être effrayant dans
les Landes on connaît Dax on connaît
Mont-de-Marsan les les plages voilà
alors simplement il y a une dissonance
on va dire l'Ifop nous dit 77% des
Français sont opposés à la corrida la
question elle est simple au nom d'une
démocratie de la majorité est-ce que
l'interdiction de la corrida ne serait
pas logique futile du est-ce que ce
serait même du suicide politique sur vos
terres d'afficionne mais voilà par
rapport à cet état de l'opinion est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas logique aujourd'hui
d'interdire la corrida
faut j'entends j'entends la j'entends la
question mais il faut faire attention
avec avec ce genre d'enquête vous savez
que par ailleurs
j'ai un passé de chercheurs en sciences
politiques donc quand on utilise les
enquêtes
ça veut pas dire que une enquête c'est
pas un vote c'est un avis et c'est un
avis qui est circonstancié à un moment
donné et puis il y a plein de il y a
plein d'avis qui sont donnés par
l'opinion publique entre guillemets mais
qui sont pas suivi d'effets les les gens
sont aussi très favorables à
l'euthanasie et pour autant il y a pas
de loi encore sur l'euthanasie donc il y
a une différence entre un débat à un
moment donné et la mise en place sur
l'agenda sur l'agenda publique après je
vais être très clair je vais être très
clair là-dessus moi je suis contre
l'interdiction à un moment donné
on oublie et vous l'avez dit en fait
parce que c'est pas un débat droit de
gauche
c'est un débat d'une certaine façon
rurale
urbain et plutôt là sur le coup c'est un
débat Nord-Sud parce que il y a déjà une
initiative il y a deux ans je me
souviens de
députés de députés modernes de députés à
l'époque qui s'était prononcé contre la
corrida en 2021 et Aurore berger faisait
partie du de ce mouvement donc on a une
tension qui traverse les forces les
forces politiques et qui reflètent une
histoire territoriale différente bien
entendu la France est une est
indivisible mais pour autant la France
c'est une mosaïque locale avec des
cultures locales qui sont différentes et
si on va dans la confrontation des uns
vis-à-vis des autres parce qu'on est
incapable de comprendre les différences
territoriales qui existent entre nous on
aura une espèce de volonté de la
bien-pensance qui doit ça qui doit
s'impliquer qui doit s'implanter partout
et qui ne respecte pas les la vie la vie
locale pendant très longtemps il y a
c'était régulier ont traité les les
Landais d'Indiens c'est c'est très bien
et Henri manuelli disait toujours en
souriant qu'on était peut-être des
indiens mais qu'on était quand même on
était quand même civilisés
est-ce que si cette proposition de loi
est votée interdire la corrida ça fait
monter le rassemblement national
je sais pas s'il y a un lien mécanique
ce que je sais en revanche c'est qu'à
force de dire à des gens sur un
territoire que la façon dont ils vivent
la façon dont il se rassemblent leur
culture locale leur le la course
landaise le gavage c'est pas bien parce
qu'on doit pas faire parce qu'on doit
pas faire comme ça c'est juste c'est
juste intolérable et encore une fois ce
n'est pas par interdiction que
fonctionne une société c'est aussi
simple que ça et on peut pas dire à
certains qu'ils doivent se conformer et
je le dis très clairement à une
bien-pensance d'une soi-disant majorité
urbaine on va remercier Xavier Sota
merci beaucoup Xavier d'avoir été avec
nous la Une de Sud-Ouest ça va faire
plaisir à suivre c'est Olivier Giroud
quelle entrée c'est à la Une évidemment
de sud-est matière de l'équipe de France
merci beaucoup Xavier Sota merci Eric et
rush d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup dans 20 minutes le territoire
on parlera de la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron au salon des mers pas de discours
devant les élus cette année dans la
visite de dans la foulée pardon de cette
visite il en recevra mille à l'Élysée on
verra tout ça dans une demi-heure
maintenant d'abord vous allez laisser
votre place à François une semaine qui
va nous rejoindre